hey guys pete here today i'm going to
break down fargo season 4 episode 3.
things are definitely in motion now
after a slower start last week as rata
parlo
which translates to double it lives up
to its name delivering a lot more
movement in the lead-up to what we have
to imagine
is an impending war between the fada and
cannon factions
to dispatch with the corn equips and
just get this out of the way
chekhov's pie played its part in leaving
us wondering if fart go might be a more
fitting title for the fourth season
i know it's terrible with those boxes
checked i do have to warn you about
spoilers if you haven't watched episode
three yet then this video won't be for
you
hit the subscribe button go watch the
third installment
and then come back once you're finished
episode 2
ended with law enforcement launching a
raid on the smutney family funeral home
we rewind and time some to see how they
arrived there
we watched us marshall dick deffy
warwick follow the trail of the escaped
convicts
zelmero roulette and swanny capps his
journey leads him to kansas city
and in a sit-down meeting with the chief
of police we learn more about who he is
he's a religious man more specifically a
mormon
which means he doesn't indulge in
caffeinated beverages
warm or cold his faith makes him an
outsider especially in missouri where
after the mormon war of 1838 his people
were ordered out of the state
by an executive order from the governor
it's a great introduction
and spirited exchange where the chief
makes a point of reminding him that
there's still
a standing kill order in place in the
state of course
timothy oliphant is quite at home in the
role of a lawman and carrot munching
deafy is a good addition to an already
large cast of characters
he gets paired up with the local cop
otis weff who's concerned when he gets
pulled off the hospital case where he
was supposed to be running cover for
josto fada
these two don't exactly get along and
after we learn that the marshall is
called deffi because he hears what he
wants to hear
we see that in action as they go back
and forth he's smug and bigoted in his
own right but he appears to be competent
at his
job that lands him in the right place to
close in on the fugitives
but they're not able to take them into
custody after opening up
five of the morgue six slabs they
encounter a particularly grotesque
corpse that causes them to head out of
the room
they were that close to finding them and
i have to say the tension in this scene
was really great
elsewhere we get the meeting of the
concierge dr
senator and abel vellante these two guys
work well in a scene together they both
come off as level-headed
strategic and comfortable in their
positions instead of getting straight to
the business of the slaughterhouses dr
veers into a monologue about his time in
world war
ii at nuremberg he spent six weeks
interviewing airman garing
coaxing a detailed confession out of him
only to see his 400 page report
with footnotes tossed in the garbage
basically he learned that his commanding
officer was just using him to get under
the nazi's skin
forcing him to answer to a black man it
sets the tone for the negotiation where
both men
know that donatello didn't give loy
permission to take the slaughterhouse
they both know that the other one knows
but that doesn't change
either side's position doctor gets up to
leave saying
the slaughterhouses they belong to us
deal or no deal you can call it the cost
of transition
oriented goes for a job interview at dr
harvard's hospital
the timing is right after the botched
drive-by it left him short-handed so she
basically gets the job because of the
nurses who got killed
in the violence josto is outside
watching him from the parking lot
plotting his revenge
orienta sees him as she's leaving and
interrupts his stakeout
she's thrilled to run into him she jokes
that he's watching her and talks to him
almost like they're in a relationship
while she thinks they've got something
going it's pretty clear that josto
doesn't remember her
that also makes it seem like he didn't
realize that their conversation was what
set things in motion for her killing his
father
one thing leads to another and she gets
him to do a bump of drugs and then she
gives him a hand job while singing the
battle hymn of the republic
this gets his attention enough to ask
her name again but she's so
self-confident in her assessment of
their budding romance that she thinks
he's playing with her
basically she rules over at the fada
house we witness some bonding between
rabbi milligan
and satchel cannon they talk about being
traded by their families
and how you have to play the hand you
were dealt i think rabbi
is one of the most interesting secondary
characters based on his story
and it's clear that makes him protective
of satchel
gaitano comes in to make sure everyone
is uncomfortable
and then he's followed by josto who's
pissed that everyone's in his office
none of this really made me like the
dynamic between these two brothers and
how it's being played anymore but it
does drive home the fact that one of
them will have to leave the picture
before
all is said and done i mean it had its
moments i think it's the eyes that
really turned me off to the gaitano
character but at the same time there's
some decent stuff in the mix
as well i mean talking about his house
being knocked down and having to live in
the trees when he was a kid
a little later we'll see him push the
limits of his position in the family to
really underline the unworkable nature
of this situation
at the canon headquarters lloyd delivers
a monologue in front of his oldest son
when a junkie comes up to ask him for
money i guess since his character's more
reserved it makes sense that we get a
look at his sadistic side
i mean it's supposed to be this life
lesson for a son and he is the leader of
a crime syndicate so he's not supposed
to be a likable character all the way
through
across the street we see zamera and
swanny hanging out casing the place
it's actually pretty funny that they
want to steal from loy in order to pay
him back on the smutney's loan
back at the king of tears swanny asks
dabrell
if it's true her family is cursed as she
finally starts digging into orienta's
syrup of epicac
pie she talks about her father and the
story has some supernatural vibes to it
i thought the look on the brell's face
stood out when she mentioned the devil
and how she said people think it's
houses that get haunted but it ain't
the close-up of the cigarette when she
took a drag and the whole thing
made me think that these ideas are going
to come back up
it also made me think about that strange
character in the street we saw when the
camera panned
from the funeral home over to orienta
standing in her window
there's no definite connection there but
i'm guessing there's gonna be some
supernatural element that's gonna come
into play
there were two major events that will
both ratchet up the tensions to close
things out
first gaitano sends the fada enforcer
constant calamita
out to strike a blow against the cannons
for the slaughterhouses
he tells him to take rabbi with him
because he wants to know
if he's loyal to the family they go
after aloy's oldest son lemuel
following him as he's leaving his
college rabbi is reluctant
because he knows this is going to start
a war and he's worried about satchel and
zero
during the pursuit he figures out that
josto didn't give the order
and when the time comes he doesn't take
the shot preventing constant from
actually getting a clean shot to kill
him he gets out of the car to walk
himself home he knows this is going to
put him on the wrong side of gaitano
but he may be able to gain favor from
josto either way
shots were fired and they were seen so
there's going to have to be consequences
the second big event is our favorite
fugitives plans to rob the canon
headquarters
when de bruyne demands to know what
they're up to swanny simply responds
being outlaws they get a ride in the
hearse where they have to share a coffin
just in case marshall deffy is doing
surveillance
while they're in there we get the idea
that they're actually a couple
and as swanny starts farting we see the
syrup of epicac is starting to wreck her
system
they still go ahead with the robbery
which is certainly more difficult as a
result of all the puking and farting
there is some suspense as things unfold
but most of it comes from swanny's
distress
as she's losing control over bodily
functions
in the end they make it out with twenty
thousand dollars but with three people
dead it's gonna wind up being about more
than just the money
the episode ends with lloyd taking stock
of the situation
dr senator tells him he thinks it could
be a coordinated action and that would
mean the start of an all-out war
loy's not really sure what to do next
because he can't really make sense of
why this is happening after all they
have each other's kids
doctor wonders who gave the order the
boss or the brother and puts it out
there that the fadas might be fighting
with each other
and he lays it out there he says once we
start shooting back it's to the death
so we better be sure and then the
credits roll
so now we can see how everything is
starting to come together things are
escalating and it's interesting that
orienta
influenced both of the big events of the
episode by
offing donatello she created the power
struggle
between the fada brothers her pie also
led to the robbery getting messy and
that was at least partially responsible
for the chaos that led to the gang
members getting
shot for me she still stands out as the
most intriguing character
and i thought swanny came in right
behind her on that list in this episode
they're both wild cards marshall deffy
seems like a great addition
dr senator was steady he stands out from
the pack
and he was especially good opposite of
valente
i could go for a sit-down meeting with
those two talking every week
rabbi was always an interesting
character and there seems to be
something
building with his story i'm curious to
see how things are going to shake out
for him considering
constant will probably try to cover his
own ass
i'm still not loving the fada brothers
at this point but it does look like
josto and orienta are heading for a
hookup that could give some credence to
the theory that she's lorne malvo's
mother
overall i thought it was a pretty solid
episode better than the last
and i'm liking how things are starting
to line up the cast still feels a little
bloated though
it's big i mean characters taking a turn
is fine but they're jumping around a lot
think about it we've only seen lloyd's
wife
once haven't seen much of zero and
satchel
which have been traded as the foundation
for
the peace and we barely checked in with
ethel rita
in this episode it's not necessarily
ruining the experience yet but i just
hope that it'll all fit together well in
the end it's a little messy but i think
it's moving in the right direction
i'm definitely curious as to how it'll
all play out the big picture items of
outsiders and people who
qualify as being the other fighting each
other over the scraps it's mostly
working
if it's a country of immigrants how does
one become an american
a few coen brother references jumped out
to me most notably the stockings on the
head in the robbery
a you've got a panty on your head moment
that h.i
from raising arizona would endorse a bit
of big lebowski slipped in there when
swanny was talking about her dad
also dude [ __ ] is not the preferred
nomenclature
and orienta saying pat or familias which
george clooney says to holly hunter
and oh brother where art thou those are
the ones that jumped out immediately to
me but let me know what other ones you
picked up on
and with that i'll leave it there let me
know in the comments what you think
what did you think about episode 3 did
you think that it's picking up momentum
what's got your interest what are you
hoping to find out in the next episode
or two
how do you think the canons are gonna
respond please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already
i'll likely be doing fargo season 4
videos throughout the season
thanks for watching guys i'll talk to
you soon